billy is i oh hell no
no
no
call an axe
which acts are you gonna call my most
recent one
oh jesus is me so awkward hello hey uh
it's nancy
it's phil it's nancy
nancy
[Music]
i think i show's right
damn that was a wrap
i know you're trying to be hurtful he
really didn't remember
like man i was i was dating four girls
at the same time nancy what's your last
name oh yes nancy edith what's up
god
hello what are you here to do today i'm
gonna call some people
call an x
okay i got one why is she dressed like a
trucker
maybe she is
doubt it
i highly doubt it with them nails i
doubt i doubt it
i'm just calling to ask you
why things didn't work out
to the guy that answered that
yes my guy yeah to the guy that answered
that yeah yes my guy yeah
honestly there's some people i don't
want to have that comment what no i just
want to know like why things didn't work
out between us
can we do this
[Laughter]
why didn't things work out between us
what is this
we had a lot of stuff going on and it
was
just the wrong time yeah shout out to
you for using vague language this is the
way to do it so that nobody looks
terrible yes i appreciate that yes yeah
an axe you're thinking i actually do
have one it'll be interesting to hear
what he has to say i
only have an ex-wife why didn't it work
out with you and your ex-wife
because it was at an age
[Laughter]
this is the most south asian
we don't have a girlfriend only
husband
i
wasn't supportive enough when she got
postpartum depression okay yeah i'll
just call brian yeah yeah that's right
we had like kind of a thing a couple of
years ago i was actually going to marry
him but he was a serial cheater
hello i was just calling to ask like
from your perspective
why you think
it didn't work out between the two of us
i had
developed feelings for somebody else i
wanted to make sure that you do instead
of you know trying to go behind your
back either one of us you know i was
trying to give up i don't know
is that the girl who's dating the serial
cheater joe
move on b
i like how the guy cheated he's like
neither one of us thought it was time to
get what for real ronnie
for real
tell me tell me why we didn't work out
fine you want me to admit it like i was
in some other videos
all right this video is weird would you
ever consider getting back together yeah
oh
having sex is fun and that was a good
time
i definitely missed that lot to think
about um thank you so much for
participating in this little phone call
all right i'll talk to you later
that's the vibes that's the vibe okay
thank you very much uh bye miss you
that was
funny were right
[ __ ] you guessed it he was like good
vibes i'm mad at that because you know a
lot of people might look at like really
that's how you miss the sex but in her
head she's like
i got that good girl and he had that
good good too so let's go we were good
good together that's what you think okay
bye see you later why
didn't we work out from your perspective
because we didn't want the same things
he wanted more
quality relationships but i wanted some
more monogamous relationships once i
told you i wanted something more open
you were like that's it i can't handle
no more
to trifling asked
i have to ask you
why things didn't work out between us
yeah that's pretty easy for me well i
was in the military i also have a very
very hard time with communication when
you're in a long-distance relationship
that's like [ __ ] key
which acts are you gonna call my most
recent one
oh jesus is me so awkward
hey uh it's nancy
it's phil it's nancy
nancy
from maryland yeah yeah yeah yeah from
here oh [ __ ] your voice sounds so
different
when i'm not your sound this voice
sounds
so different no no no what i mean is i
listen i need a plausible explanation
for when i recognize your name since you
were in my most recent next so i'm gonna
just say your voice
was a big ass ouch because he's like i
should but that's good though yeah
that's good he came yeah you have to be
quick yeah
he does that's that's that's yo the slip
on that one was good yeah
i just need to ask you a question yeah
let's do it [ __ ] yeah okay they wanted
to know why uh it didn't work out
between us i think it was mainly me i
wanted all the good things that came
with a relationship but i didn't have
any of the maturity to handle that call
a next there's no way why
i don't know if he knows he's blocked
come on come on let's do it i will
with it
for you
hello hi
hey i just wanted to call and ask why
didn't
you and i work out it's definitely
because this guy was an [ __ ]
because i was too immature there was a
lot of immaturity it just didn't feel
real
to me
but i love you always
billy billy
is that a thing
why the [ __ ] you asking me
i don't even know what that [ __ ] that
meant italy
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ] ellie
oh my love you baby
says
some people were fake like that bro you
oh wow
hello hey i just called to ask you like
why didn't we work out i just didn't
know what i wanted
and you did would you consider getting
back together
definitely i think that was the problem
yeah we can talk about that all right
well thank you for picking up bye
whoa
are you getting back together now
[Laughter]
was like it's good to know i still got
it i got it
i think things didn't work out mainly
because i was dealing with a bunch of
[ __ ] mostly it was just like an
emotional like cluster [ __ ] that was
happening there's a lot that i regret
like i wish that
i'd been more tactful tasteful in how i
ended the relationship you were
genuinely like is this the girl who's
always showing up the asian lady with
the short hair who's always showing up
in the cut videos you know that one girl
who you know they were doing the seven
versus one and they were like taking out
the white people
and then they got mad i heard the single
mom i don't remember i'm pretty sure
it's her it's possible yeah she yeah
apparently she met somebody through like
the comment section because she was like
talking about how hard dating life is
with being a mom and stuff and that dude
was in the military so i think that's
who she broke up with my friend above
everything else
and i hated the way i did it your
apology is not necessary honestly my
entire family is still pissed off and
they think it's my fault
they honestly think it's my father like
you [ __ ] up
you got an x you're thinking of i'm
either blocked or i've deleted their
number oh i don't even have any of my
ex's numbers oh you are lying and when i
break up with somebody and say you and
everybody connected to you are now no
longer in existence do you have an axe
you're thinking of we weren't
necessarily really exclusive but he's
the first person that comes to mind
hello
hey brad
hello
uh we [ __ ] tonight
i get i got you got a call from somebody
you weren't exclusive which i was
ranking y'all to talk for a while
normally they call you because you're
like
i'm [ __ ] you tonight
that's what it is
i was just calling
to
ask you
that or to say i'm pregnant or i gave
you an std
why we didn't work out
you're in a different state and i didn't
make time to come see you so
i think that's just kind of what
happened we just kind of grew apart with
the distance do you think that if i were
in the same state during that time it
would have been different yeah a little
bit
say would you move here for me
he actually lives here
yeah
well why don't halfway again bad
say would you consider going on a date
would you consider okay
this is not going to end well that's
what i was i thought well why don't
again bad
say would you consider going on a date
would you consider
going on a date with me
yeah
okay
okay
awesome
the way that she's giggling
yeah
yeah
no she's not excited at all about this
[ __ ] he's just like sure we could do
this whatever he's like yeah
that's funny to hear some of these
dynamics yeah and then she's like um but
again we also don't know the people
involved and how deep it goes so it's
just like
speculation it's a lot of fun to just
talk some [ __ ] it is yeah yeah it's
always fun to talk some [ __ ] could you
call it next
not would you but like if you could like
how do you think that would go
i don't know yeah say hey uh 20 30 years
later
no i don't think it went well i don't
think it really would not wouldn't go
well yeah uh like the ex i had i was
like in fifth grade yeah so
yeah if i call i think we should be cool
we were on facebook in the beginning of
facebook we was like i saw her yeah i
saw her in the streets a couple of times
she saw me but nothing big
i want to go out with her yeah but if
you call her you guys be cool yeah i
think would be cool it was that was
elementary so whatever
even though she went out with my cousin
hey man i guess it runs in the family
you know she runs in my family
[Laughter]
uh yeah for me same thing me i'm on good
terms with my exes oh there's a girl i
never broke up with that was actually
her friend she just ghosted me
all right we went out for a couple of
months somewhere happened i started
calling her and
she runs in your family and you run in
her friend group
yeah i'm gonna run all of them [ __ ]
but yeah well yeah yeah that's cool yeah
i got nothing to report no spiciness for
you guys so
how about good terms every now and then
each other are you good you're good cool
that's it i do find it kind of sucks
when people say all their exes like if
you had like three to four x's and you
say they're all bad
i i'll start to look at you a little bit
if all your exes were were crazy not
dating not not dates you went on even if
the dates went off but like all your
exes were big problems like damn what's
wrong with your patterns and your
choosing exactly
but maybe you guys disagree what do you
guys think you guys find it a red flag
if somebody's constantly complaining
about all their exes and their dating
partners let us know what you guys think